transcriptomics - is a course dedicated
to the statistical analysis of gene
expression data where we explore the
methods of analysis that are typically
used for extracting biological insights
from RNA seek data sets in this session
we will speak about regression as well
as factor analysis in the previous
lesson we discussed the t-test as well
as differential gene expression analysis
we analyzed data by separating the
samples into two comparison groups this
analysis can identify genes that have a
level of expression that is different
between two groups or in other words
differentially expressed genes the
conclusion step of that analysis is
biological interpretation which answers
the question of how differentially
expressed genes show biological
differences between the various
conditions we study however differential
gene expression analysis can be limited
when we have multiple conditions studied
in a dataset for example we can compare
two different conditions but we suspect
that there are additional factors at
play to learn about these types of
relationships let's discuss experimental
design types of variables and methods of
analysis to study their relationships
before this though let's review both the
underlying concepts as well as
terminology we have to understand to
study these kinds of relationships and
our data variables are terms we use to
define our data and experiment and the
external control variable related to
data collection is called an independent
variable is manipulated by what we
intend to study the data we collect are
the dependent variables and these
variables represent the measurements we
take of the conditions in the experiment
oftentimes we would like to establish a
relationship between changes in the
independent variable to establish the
relationships between measuring
dependent variables with the Causby
control sometimes this cause can be
indirect and therefore not a causal
effect even though it appears to be so
nevertheless establishing a non-random
relationship between the two is
important let's say that we collected
data on eye color Jen
age height and the weight of people we
hypothesized that some variables here
are related and some are not we also
think there are exceptions to the rule
the agent height or weight are related
but not always
relationships observed in beta can show
which variables are related unrelated
and if they are related than by how much
weight and height seemed to be logically
related but are they in this data set if
we plot a trend line we will find that
indeed it goes up the higher the height
and weight also increases but the dots
are not too close to the line and some
dots seem to be far away from it is
there a way to quantify this
relationship we have found to study this
relationship we can use a coefficient of
correlation which is also called
r-squared this measure shows how well
data and our data set is explained by
the correlation line drawn through our
data in this case we get an r-squared
coefficient of around 41% 40 is okay but
not perfect our conclusion is that
height and weight are correlated but not
perfectly let's take another example to
see what we can learn from this type of
approach ch Rab P is a gene related to
carbohydrate metabolism if we take
multiple genes that are not related to
carbohydrate intake we will not find the
correlation between intake and their
expressions if we measure this one gene
and carbohydrate intake we can quantify
their relationship by measuring both
insulin secretion as well as the level
of CHR EBP expression these two proteins
are indeed related and their levels are
correlated therefore we can study the
relationship between insulin and gene
expression we can even use this
established relationship between the two
to study additional variables such as
the Fed or fasted conditions
such relationships can be of several
types positive negative and nonlinear
linear regression is a way to further
model such a relationship to determine a
mathematical function thus explaining
the relationship between the dependent
and the independent variable in the
dataset if there is such a relationship
such a function is predictive and will
inform us of how the independent
variable will change if we change the
dependent variable the goal of
regression analysis is to find the right
coefficients of this formula that
minimizes the predictive areas based on
the data we have the regression formula
has both the dependent and independent
variables in a mathematical equation
plus a constant intercept as well as a
coefficient the dependent variable is
related to the independent variable with
additional considerations a constant
intercept or where the line starts from
and the slope of the regression line
which is also known as the coefficient
to get these variables from our data we
can use the least squares approach which
helps measure the distance from each dot
to align finding the line that best fits
the results factor analysis is a method
that uses regression to study
relationships between the data we
measure in the condition we are studying
we are interested to find variation in
the genes associated with the change in
condition as well as the unexpected
variation that comes from the
interaction between factors of the
condition we've already seen how in the
data we have several types of variables
continuous and categorical agent height
our continuous data
where's fasted state our I color a
categorical to study the relationship
between these variables and the results
we should convert the categorical
variables into numbers in the PDX
dataset we have several factors cancer
type and mouse type each one would have
to be represented as a number cancer
type can be er positive her2 negative
her2 positive as well as triple negative
modern approaches the cancer
classification led to further categories
emerging root by whether or not they
have cell receptors for mouse types we
have several types of immunodeficiency
but the level of immune deficiency
varies X ID is characterized by the
absence of the thymus gland and
therefore no t-cell production this
Mouse also has mutant B lymphocytes nod
skid stands for non obese diabetic
severe combined immunodeficiency and
mice of this type lack both mature T and
B cells a thymic nude mice are a
chthonic like XIV so they do not
synthesize t-cells however unlike XIV
they do not have mutated B cells C b-17
skid mice have affected B and T cells
however they have normal amounts of
natural killer cells macrophages as well
as granulocytes let's take a smaller
subset nod 1/8 I make for Mouse type and
ER and T n for cancer type
once our data is labeled let's prepare
the pipeline it is very simple just
connect factor analysis to start then
prepare the groups according to levels
after uploading the files drag the
appropriate name of your sample into the
right group by level and factor
combination er a positive is factor a
level one
hey thymic noon is factor B level one
nod Mouse is factor B level two so the
ER non we will place a macro and so on
when the pipeline is finished we will
get a table of output in this table we
have the gene expression data for all
samples after the last sample there are
three columns with T test results and
after that three columns of F test
results you will notice that there is a
column for each one of the two factors
and an additional column for factor
interaction in many cases when people
talk about the F test what they're
actually talking about is the F test to
compare two variants ease
however the F stat is used in a variety
of tests including regression analysis
the ciao test and the chevy test which
is a post hoc ANOVA test the F test
shows a p-value for the gene expression
relative to the factor is measured for a
low number below 0.05 will be
significant for the association with the
factor we are missing if we filter using
this group we can select those genes
that are only influenced by factor 1
factor 2 or an interaction between those
factors here's an example of a gene that
has only affected by factor 1 in this
case cancer type notice that the
variation within this group is minimal a
couple of genes that we select shut up
regulation and triple negative breast
cancer no matter what now smarter we use
PGP EP 1 l is a gene that encodes a
protein involved in the cleavage of
amino terminal pyro glutamate residues
from protein substrates including
thyrotropin-releasing hormone as well as
other neuro peptides on the other hand
Fox a1 is a gene that is upregulated in
the ER plus samples regardless of which
mouse model considerable work has linked
hormone receptors such as estrogen
receptor alpha with the pioneer factor
Fox 8:1 altered Fox a1 levels contribute
to endocrine resistant breast cancer
where it maintains ER chromatin
interactions even in context in which
cells are refractory to ER targeted
drugs if we select the columns for
factor B will find other genes these
genes are expressed in correlation with
Mouse type the genes might not be
related to cancer at all if we're using
differential gene expression however we
would find them to show differences
between cancers as well knowing this
information can help us eliminate those
genes from the ones we incorporate in
our differential expression analysis if
you take all the genes that are linked
with factor B such as type of mouse and
use the annotation utility to get go
terms for these genes we will get the
following result we expect the
differences to have some connection with
the immune system if we search for the
word immune we will find several genes
related to the immune response they're
selected after filtering in the column
for factor B as an example we can see
the gene h2 - k1 doe turns for this gene
include receptor binding positive
regulation of t-cell mediated
cytotoxicity antigen processing and
presentation of endogenous peptide
antigen via MHC class 1 here a pathway
since the gene is expressed higher in
here are positive samples but
consistently not expressed in the a
thymic newton- we can see that this type
of immune regulation is different
between types of - and therefore is more
obvious of a thymic newton - so you used
to compare between the types of cancer
if we take the last third column of the
F test we will find that there's an
unusual interaction between factors a
and B for example the difference between
expression is obvious for cancer type as
well as Mouse type but together that
difference is greater about threefold
in this lesson we learned about
dependent and independent variables
correlation and regression factor
regression analysis as well as how these
concepts and methods are used in the PBX
breast cancer project example